we got to talk about Donald Trump Donald
Trump of course is named in the court
documents but before we're not going to
bury the lead it seems to be more
exculpatory so far and I will say this
first and foremost you find in these
court
documents evidence and accusations
against Donald Trump I am alongside you
know I will say be it him or dtz or
anybody else investigate lock up anybody
who was engaged in this trafficking but
cursory search all I did they control F
Trump and what do we find
so there were a few instance uh
initially they say U Maxwell said this
is the in the closer to the beginning of
the document uh Jeffrey Epson who was a
friend of Donald Trump so I figured well
he was a good guy or whatever you know
and what she was going to learn and she
was going to learn massage therapy did
Virginia tell you this oh I can tell you
uh I can't tell you what date and time
blah blah blah so Trump is passively
mentioned here the next instance of his
mention is this uh this is a court
statement not an interview the other the
other portions of the of the court
records are
uh inter interview with Witnesses and
victims in this one it says three Donald
Trump was a good friend of Mr Epstein
and quote flirted with me now here's
what interesting jump to the next
instance of Donald Trump she says okay
and what else did you put a check by
quote Donald Trump was a good friend of
Jeff he didn't partake in any sex with
any of us but he flirted with me he'd
laugh and tell Jeffrey you've got the
life other than the three you've just
mentioned everything else on here is
absolutely accurate yes what the witness
is saying is the that statement that
quote is not accurate you jump to the
next instance all right what's
inaccurate about the last statement on
the page quote Donald Trump was also a
good friend of Jeff that part is true
quote he didn't partake in any of any
sex with us but he flirted with me it's
true that he didn't partake in any sex
with us but it's not true that he
flirted with me Donald Trump never
flirted with me he'd laugh and tell
Jeffrey you've got the life I never said
that to her when you say he didn't
partake in any sex with us who is is us
girls how do you know who Donald Trump
had sex with she says I didn't
physically see him have sex with any of
the girls so I can't say who he had sex
with in his whole life or not I just
know it wasn't with me when I was with
the other girls it looks like while
Trump is mentioned they do mention like
going to the casino one of the more
fascinating things is apparently someone
says we tried to go to Trump's Casino in
Atlantic City but Virginia couldn't get
in she was underage Trump's
establishment was like you're too young
you can't come in
that's this is really interesting now
I'm not I'm not trying to play games
where we're just here to attack
Democrats and defend Donald Trump okay
we need a full accounting of these court
documents and the accusations secondly
innocent until proven guilty Alan dtz of
course is accused of raping a minor in
this and that may or may not be true he
should be he should be investigated now
and and there should be legitimate
investigation but I I say we got to be
careful about this I'm inclined to say I
believe there's a moral of Truth here
right right off the B my inclination is
to believe the victims but I still don't
think we should just jump off the boat
and be like it's a fact it's proven we
we need real criminal investigations and
accountability on this this this
document is from a defamation lawsuit in
a defamation lawsuit you can say
anything you want it doesn't make it
true yeah I mean look this is the the
troubling part here is this is so
pervasive at the highest levels of power
so just investigating it's going to be
difficult in itself
and as just watching it unfold and since
this has started it's actually made me
feel kind of small I feel like I have no
effect whatsoever on anything when I see
this kind of stuff happening and my
voice doesn't matter and my voice
doesn't matter toe when you talk your
microphone let's pretend I'm silent here
let's let's let's read more real quick
it says uh what is the basis for your
statement that Donald Trump is a good
friend of Jeff's answer Jeffrey told me
that Trump is a good friend of his who
in the world at the time would not say
and try and brag about
Donald Trump it's name dropping she said
the question is have you ever observed
them together answer no not that I
actually can actually remember I mean
not not off not off the top of my head
when did Trump flirt with you he didn't
that's what that was inaccurate did you
ever see Donald Trump at Jeff's home not
that I can remember on his Island no not
that I can remember in New Mexico no not
that I can remember in New York not that
I can remember all right if you could
turn to the second page etc etc so far
like right when you open up this court
document I mean this is just one this is
just one I'm not saying all of them and
you search Trump instantly it's like no
he wasn't there he didn't flirt with you
that wasn't true I couldn't get into
Casino I was underage wow that's that's
interesting yeah I mean look if it comes
out like you said that anything at all
uh you know implicates
Trump I that's why I think they're going
to twist the mara Lago thing like I'm
only looking at one document too and
again there's a there are a lot that
have come out but the idea that
potentially galain Maxwell went to Mar
Lago to recruit underage girls who had
jobs there I mean it doesn't matter that
they were working legally you know as
whatever at at marago working the Spa
doing whatever waitressing jobs but it
would be interesting to see the media
and I believe this is what will happen
is like oh well then why did Trump let
her go there if he knew she was
recruiting women because that was her
role in Epstein's organization and it's
going to be this end endless re reaching
for straws anything to tie the narrative
together the way they want it to and
what's sad is that ultimately there are
young women who were victimized by this
person and it doesn't matter because
they weren't victimized by someone
they're to prute it like the the issue
never actually matters it's the same
reaction or it will be the same reaction
to this kind of stuff in regard to Trump
as it was to like uh Kavanaugh when he
was uh you know when he was when he was
before he was confirmed falsely accused
yeah he was falsely accused and they
they drummed up you know produced people
that will lie under oath nothing ever
happens to them you know for for lying
but you know it it it serves a purpose
which is only to retain aain power for
the people that are on the either the
left or the people in The Establishment
establishment I just really hope my that
this wakes up just a few people you know
what I mean if some people can follow
this and they can change just slightly
because of this to be a little bit less
trusting of the establishment to be a
little less bias I think that's an
achievement in itself I think that would
be one positive of this you know
situation but again I mean I've just
seen it unfold since the beginning I've
seen the the incredible defense of
people who are clearly not worth
defending and I I don't and it's not
just this it's been continual there's
been this kind of you know we talked
about psychogenic epidemics in my
documentary in these social experiments
there there's a certain degree of mass
hysteria that takes place over issues
now where people can literally justify
or defend anything here's the setup Phil
mentions they can get anybody to lie
under oath for we saw those women in the
Kavanaugh case claim that they were
gangbang parties where they were men
were lining up outside of rooms to rape
women total fabric
out of nothing and we know that
Christine blasy Ford her stories were
nuts she was like I'm scared to fly did
you fly here yes did you fly on vacation
yes what are you talking about what do
you think happens we get to on October
surprise a woman comes out and says she
was a victim of Jeffrey Epstein Donald
Trump did
it it's all it takes that's all it takes
especially nowadays with the media the
way it's going to run with it and it's
going to become the biggest I just think
it'll be less credible than I mean with
Kavanagh you saw a huge Division and
people who believed it no matter what
definitely whoever was accusing Kavanagh
was was right whereas there were a lot
of people who were challenged it there
were a lot of people who said this is
not legitimate this case is coming out
of nowhere I stand by Kavanagh whatever
else he ultimately was uh approved for
the Supreme Court and I think it's
similar with Trump right like Trump
already had to face some weird charge of
you know sexual battery or whatever in a
story in which there's no proof that he
even had ever had contact with this
woman they've tried to convict him on
these grounds before both in the court
of public opinion with the like grab by
whatever quote and in actual court and
it does not change the fact that his
supporters don't believe it it it's a
difficult position I mean it could that
could be the case with the October
surprise that you know Donald Trump's on
the list and we have credible evidence
that it was him but I ultimately think
that they have made him such a
villainized man that his supporters will
fall in line behind him and he's accused
of so much we've sort of hit our
threshold you don't really believe that
this wealthy famous guy who's already
been accused of this before nobody knew
believes because the people that are the
people that were inclined to to believe
it they were already going to believe it
no matter what you said negatively about
Trump but there's no one else to win
over I me doesn't that point to such a
such a big issue at this point that what
you're pretty much saying is that
regardless of evidence regardless of
what comes forward people have made up
their minds about Trump yeah for sure so
it doesn't matter if he is guilty if
he's not guilty if evidence comes out if
it doesn't come out the people who
support him and we're in a position
where we can't even trust what comes out
anymore anyway I mean what I want to
know is Biden's on the the list that's
my actual question because with Bill
Clinton is and with Biden and we have a
bunch of other Democratic supporters
again people already have their
political bias and I hate to feed into
that but the real question is is the
October surprise going to be that Joe
Biden had contact with Jeffrey
Epstein I I don't my opinion I I still
don't I don't think that it's it's I
still don't think that it's as much
about Trump as it is about you know I
think Trump is is a symptom of of
everything I think if it wasn't trump it
would be someone else you know that that
would be getting the the negative
attention so I I'm I still kind of stick
to that opinion you know what what is it
about people in power doing sick things
like this though what is what is the
weird like when does that happen that
Insanity that takes over your mind no no
no it's it's actually really simple if
you are an
abuser and like you're looking for a way
to get away with it you need power to
protect yourself when you commit crimes
that makes sense that like DC is the
highest density of sociopaths people who
want Power they're going to go to DC
that's the place to get it people want
to break law and commit crimes you got
stupid criminals who run into a Walmart
and snatch things around the door you
got smart criminals who get elected to
congress and then Insider trade yeah
growing up I just thought that this was
such an obscure rare thing to actually
happen and as I've gotten older I've
sadly had to accept the fact that it's
far more pervasive what that like sexual
deviancy or people abusing their
position of power no child rape yeah
it's I mean I think this is like the
weird thing which is that we know there
are children trafficked all over the
world but for some reason we don't think
it happens here in the US we think it
happens somewhere else but ultimately
people in the US either go somewhere
else or it has to happen on our door
there's no way the numbers could bear up
otherwise thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net